let's take a look behind the scenes of
John Wick 4. Keanu Reeves didn't train
for three months for nothing the guy is
given NASCAR racing a run for their
money with his 180 drifts and high-speed
chases of course not without a handful
of onset injuries and accidents though
let's get into it this was a major
aspect of his training that definitely
deserves its own highlight I got to do
some more driving and not just any
ordinary driving yeah I'm talking about
Airy driving driving that you would
never want to do with mom in the car
they took the car stunts to
all they're more complex now than they
used to be and luckily for Keanu he
really enjoyed it it's really fun to be
in the car again he had to do some
high-speed 180s and 270s but the hardest
scene he had to master was when he did a
reverse 180 and Thrift while reloading
his prop Gun and shooting out the
freaking door major props to Keanu and
his stunt team on that one you should
know that after four movies Keanu Reeves
is no one to be messed with the guy must
be made of like steel or something
there's a car food gone through and now
sword food there's lots of fooling rap
he's known for doing as many stunts as
possible so obviously he had to go
through some brutal training in order to
get there like the guy trained for 12
weeks to achieve what they called the
toolbox basically a toolbox of skills
that he could utilize for the films he
literally learned how to stunt drive
like the pros the art of Judo Jiu Jitsu
and how to professionally wield
nunchucks he describes this film as the
most difficult physical role he's had in
his entire career and like the fact that
it took four of these movies for him to
say that is really something else gun
training martial arts training driving
training he's always first man there
last man to leave our guy was training
five days a week for eight hours a day
and it truly seems like he was having a
a great time doing it when it's time to
hit the gym or hit a specific skill set
he's always there he's always been
incredibly involved of course it also
helps that he's been
binge and performers in the biz I've
never worked with an actor who's willing
to work that hard train that hard the
guy's an animal like I didn't think it
was possible to be more impressed with
Keanu Reeves but here we are there's a
super intense scene where he's just
blasting through guys left and right and
the camera is hovering just above him
yeah that was just multiple really long
takes there weren't a ton of cuts
happening in that moment it was pretty
high pressure but luckily the cameras
were automated so it was a lot less work
for the crew but it didn't take any
weight from keanu's shoulders he
couldn't see the cameras but they did
have certain movements programmed into
them so he had to make sure he was in
sync with every one of them if there was
just one little mistake he had to reset
from the beginning and I don't know
exactly how many takes it took him but
knowing Keanu I would probably be
incredibly impressed with that number
naturally though mistakes were made some
of them hospital-inducing you know there
had to be at least a few injuries on the
set of this movie I'm actually more
surprised at how few there were I made a
mistake once and I cut a gentleman's
head open
ouch okay brutal that's got to be the
worst of it right well one guy got hit
by a car was in the car he had to go to
the hospital fortunately there weren't
any other major accidents none that were
accounted for in the media anyway but
yeah so that really sucked excuse my
language Donnie Yen put a lot of thought
into the fighting style of Kane it
wasn't even really about the martial
arts for him it was more about his
personality in any of his films he never
really focuses on the style of martial
arts when it comes to developing how his
character fights this guy his family man
introvert calms walk slow talk slow so
that's probably not something we as the
audience would pick up on right but you
can see those personality traits show up
in like every fight scene therefore his
movements is barely reserved he only
reacts to an outside force all obviously
I'm talking about Keanu Reeves and
Laurence Fishburne here as you no doubt
have guessed
I am Morpheus like these two are thick
as thieves they've been friends ever
since their Matrix days over a decade
ago so it's no surprise that the set of
John Wick is a lot more fun and
lighthearted than you'd think Lawrence's
favorite thing about Keanu is actually
his sense of humor so in between getting
punched in the face Keanu is cracking
jokes and making the whole set laugh he
makes you laugh a lot does he yeah he's
got a great sense of humor you also
might have unknowingly seen them on one
of their bro bonding trips we taking
some nice motorcycle rides not gonna lie
ever since I heard Lawrence Fishburne
describe the stunts filmed in Paris as
breathtaking and completely off the
chain it's been everything I've been
wanting to see on screen one thing I
know for sure is that Keanu has many
scenes where he's moving through or
rather fighting through hundreds of
extras this was one of the most tedious
and difficult scenes to capture mostly
due to the fact that they didn't want
anybody getting hurt the setup for these
moments took longer than you could ever
imagine too so yeah let's talk about
that for a sec you know you gotta go on
the playground a little bit how long do
you think it takes to set up a John Wick
fight scene if you guessed days weeks or
even months you'd be right Lawrence
Fishburne says that's one thing he
always forgets until he steps on to set
he says everything happens between the
words action and cut seem like magic but
it's not it's all prep again days weeks
and months worth of it that's always fun
one when you can still continually to
expand your own ideas I know I talked a
little bit about the fight scenes and
the carfoo but I need to shout out the
stunt coordinator Scott Rogers who
actually worked with Keanu Reeves to
give us the ultimate car chase scene
Keanu is so dedicated to performing his
own stunts that he started training nine
months in advance to hone his driving
skills like can you actually believe it
all that work definitely paid off
because Scott Rogers tailored that scene
specifically to keanu's driving caliber
not the other way around he actually
started getting too good in the car so
as I've already discussed a lot Keanu
Reeves has a major set of skills
although yes a huge part of that was
because of all the long hard hours of
training he did but what makes John Wick
so great is that the stunt
choreographers work with his natural
strengths they already know how he moves
so it eliminates hours and hours of
training him to move in a different way
we kind of watch and see he does best
and then we just figure out okay that
movement looks best for him here even if
they don't need that particular movement
if he looks good doing it they'll
incorporate it somewhere else we're
trying to get it right we're trying to
catch the magic yeah let's talk about
the elephant in the room covet
unfortunately delayed this movie an
entire year not only that but they also
didn't want John Wick to be competing
against top gun Maverick in 2022 at the
box office so they went ahead and pushed
it back another year it was announced in
a teaser trailer that yeah was a little
disappointing to see but Charming enough
to be forgiven that's cool that's kind
so who else was super bummed about the
delays I have no clue but uh you know I
wish everybody good luck so I just
re-watched all the John Wick movies
because of the new one and I had to know
just how they did those crazy stunts how
long do they practice is that really
Keanu what would I need to study to
become a master assassin I mean do they
just give Keanu like a fake gone and say
go I want to know what's the difference
between a John Wick fight scene and all
the other fight scenes out there that
don't look nearly as good according to
the director behind the Citizen Kane of
gunfights Chad stachowski it comes down
to essentially one thing preparation a
ton of the movie's budget often goes to
fancy hotels food and other services
that don't really have to do with the
movie itself forced to helski all that
is out the window he wants to spend all
that cash on being more prepared than
anyone else in Hollywood according to
him the typical three or so weeks people
spend on making fight scenes is
ridiculous he knows of no one who
becomes world class at something in
three weeks instead those fast-paced
sequences are prepared over a period of
months if not years the team behind the
scenes will beat up the script until the
action beats are just perfect then
they'll design each and every action
sequence over a painstaking process of
violent brainstorming then the actors
trained for months with not just the
best stunt team out there but actually
mercenarios who do this kind of thing in
real life finally when it comes time for
my man Chad to shoot that scene they
have got it in like five or so days of
shooting of course there's another step
after that that you might be surprised
about all these movies might look so
real that they could basically be a
documentary series about keanu's side
gig as a super assassin but they have a
lot more CGI than you think before I
break your heart showing you the CGI
behind the scenes be sure to like And
subscribe real quick that's what Keanu
would do probably okay so it's super
impressive when you see a really cool
CGI alien character like Thanos or an
entire city get destroyed in an epic CGI
battle that's not the best CGI though no
trust me the best CGI is the CGI you
can't even spot when you think of the
John Wick movies you think of gritty
stunt work not computer generated action
it's not fast and furious well guess
what the CGI and the John Wick series is
phenomenal the digital effects team is
always working in the background
sometimes literally on the backgrounds
many of the over-the-top locations in
the film that they have these
over-the-top fight scenes in are
actually in front of a green screen
though the shot that truly blew my mind
was when I saw the big Keanu Reeves
motorcycle chase fight from John Wick
chapter 3 was full of CGI Keanu may have
been on a motorcycle but he wasn't
actually racing through New York City
having sword fights at like 80 miles per
hour I mean I'm sure he does that all
the time and is off hours but not in the
movie he's certainly trained enough for
it can you even imagine John Wick with
anyone other than Keanu not really well
that really couldn't have happened
because the way those movies are shot
pretty much require someone with Keanu
Reeves levels of training to do it right
most action movies like this feature
Quick Cuts or special tricks to hide the
stunt performers switching out a John
Wick fight scene keeps the camera on
Wick himself and just pans around with
him as he delivers Carnage left and
right in a ballet of blood and bullets
there's really no way to hide a
stuntman's switch so Keanu Reeves is
doing it like 90 of the time that means
he's pretty much got to have enough
skills to be a pro assassin in real life
seriously look at this dude running
through the gun range with Halle Berry
if he ever needed to retire from acting
he could have a legit career as an
assassin that would probably be at John
Wick's level there's no way 90 of real
world assassins have this kind of skill
as you can see that requires months of
Judo training weapons training driving
training all as prep work that's just to
provide general knowledge and muscle
memory after watching him do all his
training I want to see him fight Tom
Hardy in a real Judo match 20 bucks on
reefs after he gets his training down
then he has to do incredible amounts of
rehearsal so that the fights look just
right for the fourth film he had to
train for three months to get all the
choreography down that included learning
new skills like nunchucks and more
driving techniques what's truly insane
is that he had to combine all his skills
into one next level stunt in pair virus
while driving he's got to do a reverse
180 drift around the arc to Triumph
reload his gun and then fire out the
door all with the kind of precision we
would expect from Mr Wick I mean if they
let him do all that what would they not
let him do knowing that Keanu Reeves
does 90 of the stunts in the wick movies
makes me want to know when is it not
Keanu Reeves I'm the kind of fan who
watches the Mandalorian and tries to
figure out when the Mandalorian is
actually Pedro Pascal under there
instead of his stunt doubles Brendan
Wayne and Latif Crowder truth be told
it's pretty easy to tell when it's not
Keanu just look at any instant where
John Wick is hit with a car nearly lit
on fire or thrown around excessively
cause while directors may have to have a
panic attack watching Tom Cruise fling
himself and the actual film into
horrible danger Chad stachowski has no
interest in being the guy who offs Keanu
Reeves don't get me wrong he's nothing
but praise for Reeves and his stunt
credit stahowski used to be a stunt guy
one who actually stunted 4K piano during
the Matrix movies and he actually said
when it comes to driving a car handling
a gun or remembering fight choreography
Reeves is actually better than most Pro
stunt performers out there including
himself so he feels pretty comfortable
with Reeves doing all that dangerous
stuff just anytime you see Mr Wick get
thrown off a building wrecking a car
getting stabbed getting slammed into
something or just generally beaten to a
pulp that's probably his stunt double
you don't notice it because that next
level CGI team edits out the stunt
performer's face and puts in Kiana's
that's all well and good but if I was in
one of those dangerous scenes and I
didn't get to work with Keanu I'd be so
mad according to pretty much everyone he
is a joy to work with of course the only
question I really want answered is what
it's like to work with Keanu Reeves on
these movies unsurprisingly it seems
like it's pretty awesome Lawrence
Fishburn is the guy most likely to show
up in a Keanu Reeves movie he's seen
Reeves go from Neo from The Matrix all
the way to full Baba Yaga mode as far as
filming the wick series series goes
Fishburn didn't have the best time I
mean don't get me wrong he loves the
series and he loves the Bowery King but
making these movies is apparently super
tedious and slow no wonder he's done so
much TV lately as far as Reeves goes
though Fishburn basically said John Wick
chapter 4 was the most hardcore he's
seen his old kung fu buddy go he said
the Judo Reeves showed off was literally
Next Level that's keanu's buddy though
how much can we trust his word really
well Donnie Yen it man himself does not
hold back when it comes to his American
movies he recently called out pretty
much all the American films he's done
from Rogue one to even John Wick 4
saying that they all tried to play up
the same stereotypes that he had to put
his foot down about the man badmouthed
his own movie right before its release
date so his word is pretty trustworthy
he actually said that his time with
Keanu and Chad stachowski was the best
time he's had on a Hollywood movie if
Donnie yed says that you're a nice guy
to work with you know it's true because
he would definitely tell everyone if it
wasn't so like have you guys ever
wondered what John Wick looks like under
all that CGI well ever since I found
these behind the scenes videos of how
they make the John Wick movies I've been
obsessed and it's not just because I'm a
big Keanu Reeves fan I'm a huge Keanu
Reeves fan
your breathtaking I know that if you're
watching this you're a big piano fan too
which is why you'll be happy to know
that he actually did all his own stunts
for the John Wick movies no CGI there at
all he can do everything he's just
even at age 50 Keanu Reeves is a
professionally trained martial artist
but he didn't get those Mad Skills from
taking a spin class and being over 50
the physical limitations that one gets
at that age has to be overcome with even
more hours of physical fitness training
for five months before filming he
literally trained eight hours a day for
five days a week that's like working out
as a full-time job when we train them
we'll go for hours and hours and hours
and he just won't stop during those five
months kyuno focused on fighting martial
arts and all sorts of totally awesome
moves you don't get to show up and do
what he does without having a stellar
work ethic and obviously he's also a
certified Stunt Driver he's a phenomenal
driver and Stunt Driver and that
to be able to put him in a lot more of
the shops it took them like three months
to choreograph this taxi Warehouse scene
with Keanu at the wheel the whole time
if Tokyo drifted through the streets of
Manhattan wasn't cool enough the stunt
team also elevated this ramp to give the
Mustang some serious air when it
launched onto the street although I'm
not sure I'd feel totally safe if he was
my Uber driver no offense Keanu okay
confession time Keanu Reeves doesn't do
all his own stunts well yeah I could get
hit by a car but you know hospital when
a scene demands just a bit more action
than Keanu can give he calls in the pros
for some backup John Wick will get hit
by a car and that's Jackson spidell you
guys just side note Josh spidel is like
the king of stunts besides John Wick
he's been in a ton of Marvel movies
honestly I think he's too cute to be a
stunt actor but that's just me sorry
Moving on but speaking of cute
is that the dog
he likes you
no CGI here the John Wick dogs are
totally real as far as dog movies that
I've worked on this is one of the most
apparently there's this Corporation
Called animal actors International
that's like this database of animals who
act I wonder if Danny DeVito is
represented by them kidding we love you
Danny but that's where the John Wick
people found all their canine actors who
honestly all deserve Oscars they're so
talented a very special Beagle named
Andy played the part of Daisy who
unfortunately had a limited amount of
screen time I'll tell you what happened
to Andy after they finished filming John
Wick in a sec but first I gotta touch on
the CGI so we all know CGI can be used
for a ton of different things even stuff
you wouldn't expect like lighting
de-aging technology is sorry shiny
Robert De Niro fog even kissing we set
such higher standards on the first two
movies that you always have to kind of
one up with it but apparently this
technology is a lot more complicated
than I thought we got to put things on
the edge of what's real and still make
it cinematic okay I know most of the CGI
and the John Wick movies are super legit
but they're was one thing they faked
that I just couldn't get over this right
here was CGI and it cost the filmmakers
five thousand dollars seriously guys
couldn't you just get chocolate or
something well they did spend the rest
of that 25 million dollar budget pretty
well though
sucks did you know green screens are
green because green is the furthest
color away from many different skin
tones so when CGI is added in post the
character's skin won't get canceled out
in the Final Cut so does that mean I
should wear as much green as possible if
I'm camera shy well what if I want to be
totally invisible I should probably wear
one of these full body green screen
outfits the VFX team used to film this
motorcycle scene yeah we just wanted to
put some dudes in green suits really it
was pretty great I just wanted to
embarrass the stunt team this motorcycle
scene was actually inspired by a similar
fight scene from the 2017 South Korean
film The villainous which Keanu and John
Wick director Chad stachowski had both
seen and loved we started trying to
figure it out oh this is what they did
this is really interesting it was like a
puzzle we tried to piece together well
I'll tell you why this was the most
difficult scene to film but first I
gotta give you that update on the Beagle
well shortly after Andy retired from
Show Business he was adopted into a
loving family who renamed him Wick
that's so cute Daisy
of course dogs weren't the only live
animal on the set of John Wick do you
guys remember when Keanu rides a literal
horse throughout the streets of the city
not only did Keanu have to learn stunt
driving for these films he also had to
learn stunt horse riding Chad was like
time to train on a horse for real it's
all legit it's it's John Wick it's like
it's just instead of just riding a horse
you have to have a gun fight well
apparently it took Keanu hundreds of
hours to learn how to ride but that just
goes to show how talented and devoted he
really is riding a horse was too easy
for Keanu Reeves so we had him do trick
riding ain't that one good looking
Cowboy this is been something we've been
working on for a couple months to try
and get this thing right so the
motorcycle fight scenes were definitely
the most difficult scenes to shoot we
have a CGI sequence it's been
challenging because it's so outside of
what we normally do the filmmakers used
a combination of Studio green screen
stunts the stunt team worked out the
choreography first and then everything
else will come after that and live
action shots on location in New York for
some high speed action I'm serious they
had stunt bikers going over 100
kilometers an hour for these shots then
they cgi'd keanu's face onto one of the
stunt drivers for the final cut
everything we did had to have a visceral
reaction to the audience okay guys now
this is some real movie Magic for this
motorcycle scene in particular the VFX
team had to add CGI to shots that were 1
000 frames long that's 1 000 different
images that had to be altered
individually and seamlessly edited
together to create a continue newest
image and here I thought editing
Instagram reels was like serious editing
there's more of a partnership with
stunts and visual effects than people
know turns out there's no chat GPT for
movie making a computer make me an epic
fight sequence so how do they make it
safe for the actors to pull off these
sweet moves you remember that famous
fight scene that seemed to take place in
that knife Museum well all that glass
special effects well some of it was real
also special custom made glass to show
up better on screen and only explode on
you it was visually edited in post by
the VFX Department to give it that shiny
cinematic look so many of the physical
props in John Wick were real which
probably made it easier for the audience
to get lost in the magic of John Wick
well I can't help but be totally
impressed with these actors like how
hard would it be to keep a straight face
while you're doing this kind of scene I
think if there's any other action actor
or actor there wouldn't be a John work I
think he's the only one that could play
him alright I literally didn't think it
was possible for me to love Keanu Reeves
any more than I already did sometimes
life has a funny way of surprising you I
guess but what about you guys are you
impressed with his sick moves
foreign